pop a hole in the container put the
straw through it and there you go hey
everyone I am kaya I am the former
McDonald's employee and here are 10 ways
you're eating McDonald's wrong so
instead of ordering and sausage Egg
McMuffin you can order a sausage
McMuffin and just add egg it does save
you a few cents and as a former worker I
do know the smartest customers were the
ones that but fall apart and just added
the extras on top so this also applies
to other food items on the menu such as
some of the sandwiches it is usually
just cheaper to order the extras on top
[Music]
tip number two using your fright
container as a burger holder to avoid
messy situations if you're someone who's
a messy eater like a lot of us you can
put the burger in the fry container and
while you're eating the little extra
bits are gonna fall in the container and
later you can just pick those out eat
them if you want to and the extra bits
from the burger also won't fall on your
clothes while you're driving and eating
at the same time for example so tip
number three McDonald's on the go say
you're running late for work or you're
at college and you're walking what you
can do is punch a little hole through
the container and put it on the straw
and there you go so you can drink with
this you can take a bite of your burger
you can have some fries all in one hand
on the go
[Music]
tip number four is adding Mac sauce to
your french fries it's kind of like
animal style fries but it's inexpensive
and it's kind of like your own homemade
version back when I worked there I
discovered this and I ate there so many
times probably more than I should have
but I really enjoy it honestly and if
you have never tried this you should
definitely try tip number five is the
budget picnic basically you take a
double ask for no ketchup and no mustard
and instead add Big Mac sauce I tried
this in my first week of working there
and I loved it the taste is honestly
really similar to the regular Big Mac
and it's so much cheaper so yeah why not
tip number six is bring your own salad
and then just add chicken nuggets into
it it's like the best of both worlds you
can get your little unhealthy bits of
chicken nuggets but also have your salad
and also it is probably gonna be the
cheaper times fast food salads kind of
get expensive and the Nuggets themselves
are usually pretty cheap
[Music]
tip number seven is knowing that you can
add egg to any burger on the menu that
you want so here we have a Big Mac and
you can add egg to the sandwich to make
it and date back the APAC is knowing
that you can order either the round egg
or the folded egg on any say what you
want so you can add it to a breakfast in
order to a lunch sandwich and you can
you know that you have the option to
like switch it up whenever you want
for example the McCrystal circular
sandwich to me it makes more sense to
add the sir the circular egg onto it
because well circular sandwich
[Music]
tip number nine is if you take McFlurry
top say you're driving you're eating
your nuggets on the go you take the
McFlurry top and you put your sauce in
the top as a holder say you're driving
you can just take a McNugget and dip it
in there knowing it's secure you won't
make a mess and yeah that's how you can
eat them on the go and still dipping
them into your sauce tip number 10 just
remember that all the felons employees
are human don't forget to treat them
with respect sometimes things happen
order is misplaced takes a little while
but employees are working as hard as
they can and nicer you are more likely
to give you freebies remember your
orders get you out a little quicker get
in and out a little quicker and yeah so
my name is kaya and this was ten ways
you're eating McDonald's wrong
[Music]